so before we go
into this fascinating darwinian
evolution of cryptocurrencies
uh let me ask you sort of a basic
programming question
there's a fascinating aspect to your
work with cardano that use haskell
as uh to build the infrastructure but
even stepping back
more looking at this landscape another
place where
darwinian evolution operates look at
this landscape of programming languages
you as an engineer you as a philosopher
both what programming languages do you
think are interesting
and more practically what programming
languages if you were to advise
like students today should they learn
yeah
so there's the pedagogy of learning how
to program and and to express the theory
of computer science like you have to
learn how to write algorithms you have
to learn what data structures are you
have to be able to do analysis of these
things and
that probably the i think the debate is
over python is probably the best
language or
javascript to get started with because
they're very useful the libraries are
amazing there's just tons of online
materials
even mit is now teaching their
introduction to computer science and
python
uh and they used to do lisp i mean these
these guys were hardcore i still love
listening oh man it's great you know
these are your father's parentheses
they're elegant weapons from from a time
long ago
uh but you know that's that's a great
starting point and it's not about
falling in love with the language it's
just falling in love with computing it's
about falling in love with
having a dialogue with a computer and
thinking about well how would i solve
that how would i interact with that what
what does this need to look like
functional programming is what we've
chosen to use for
cardano mostly because we're living in
the academic world we've written 105
papers
and the problem is you have to translate
that work into code
and the gap between an imperative
language like a c plus plus or c
and these academic rigorous papers is
extremely
large and so there's going to be a lot
of semantical ambiguity between those
two
and what i mean by that is that you
might end up implementing
a wrong thing you might think that what
you've built is the paper but
the computer's not going to tell you
that because the paper is written in
prose and maybe
typed up in latex or something but
there's no proof
chain evidence chain that you can show
that there's no ambiguity
when you look at a functional language
you're a little closer to math
and so as a consequence the translation
of the papers that we spent so damn long
writing and writing proofs about and so
forth
to code is much smaller now the downside
is these functional languages tend to be
a bit
more academic and they tend to have not
necessarily the best windows support and
the libraries aren't so good and also
they tend to be a little slower when
compared
as a whole on average to languages like
c for example
so it's really a question of okay what
are you designing for for version one
are you designing for
performance and are you designing for
developer accessibility
are you designing for correctness and
are you designing for
uh the a high fidelity representation of
the protocol
okay so haskell was chosen as kind of
the version one because we knew
that the kinds of people who think about
that are also the kinds of people that
would have an easy time reading a paper
like aura boris
and working their way through all of
this and they would do a pretty good job
writing a formal specification
and then translating that into running
code then once you have that
you have a blueprint that you can
actually reason about maintain
and if you really wanted to you could
then turn that into a rust code base or
into a java code base
going the other way around would be you
know kind of kind of pointless and
counterproductive
the other side of it is that
casco code or functional code tends to
be significantly more concise and i
actually have a real life example of
that
so if you take a look at mantis we
implemented a full ethereum node
in scala it's only about 14 or 15 000
lines of code
you compare that with like c plus plus
bitcoin i think that's 120 150 000 lines
of code
so it's almost 10 times smaller and so
less code
less to read and you tend to read code
significantly more than
you would read write code so
it's always an advantage for maintenance
understandability
documentation and other things when you
have more
concise code bases and also it's it's a
lot
easier for you to apply uh stronger
tools to a functional code base
uh like static analysis or
property-based testing or these types of
things
uh than an imperative code base but you
know the thing is it's almost like a
religion it's like say or or language
it's like saying what's
french versus russian versus english
everybody has their adherence they say
oh
they have the best poetry here or
russian yeah yeah there you go always or
in russian
everybody has their favorite tools their
their favorite languages
but it just comes down to what problems
are you trying to solve and what problem
domain do you live in
if you're inventing new protocols based
on science you're going to take the time
to write a paper go through the peer
review process
as you've done personally you know how
hard it can be to get into a conference
and go through that and get your ass
kicked
then you also have to apply the exact
same level of care
to the engineering side in terms of
implementation of that or else you will
make a mistake and that mistake will
probably be an exploit in the system
that
destroys the security properties of the
system so we really had no choice
but to go to some notion of functional
the question was what's the goldilocks
language do you use a hybrid language
like scala and f sharp or closure
where you still have some connection to
understandable things
like net or the jvm or do you
go to an overly academic language like
idris or agda
or you know isabel and in there you can
really
dial up the correctness and write all
kinds of crazy proofs but by the way
it's like
the seven people who write your code
they go on vacation a lot you'll never
get anything done
so haskell kind of felt like a nice
middle ground between those two where
we needed to pull in to the left we
could if you wanted to pull into the
right you could as well
that said it's really amazing to see
what the hybrid languages have done if i
was a new student in computer science
and i said you know learn any language
to grow your career from uh scholar
three
is probably the language to go with
interesting yeah it's great because it's
like
you want it to be like java it's java
and it looks kind of like a java program
you want it to be like python and
scripted
and you use a reply you can do that you
want to go hardcore
dot you know dependent object types and
do like weird proofs and stuff in the
functional you do all that
you have access to all of these things
and martin odersky is a brilliant guy
he's done some
phenomenal work basically because he was
a he was one guy created jvm and he's
worked on compilers for
over 20 years he he did a lot of really
hardcore work and trying to build a
concise
nice modern language that does a little
bit of everything
and it's got great applications in data
science and ai
it's also heavily used in modern
companies like netflix uses scala for
all of their microservice architecture
yeah so there's that's a great language
and it's easy to pick up and it's easy
to hire people into
you just find these eastern european
guys who are java programmers for 10
years 15 years and they got tired of
making
20 an hour so they picked up scala so
they can make 35 dollars an hour
and they're really good at it you know
and that's a great gateway drug because
you know
like quick check and haskell you have
scala check and scala you know you can
also
build do model checking you can also go
and use a tla spec and and make it work
with scala and so forth
so it's a it gets you a little bit of
everything and
you know you can then move around that
entire design space in a beautiful way
so the recommendation is uh maybe if you
want to go
vanilla you go python and javascript
when you're getting started it's the
getting started that'll get you
everything
and then your web scrapers and anything
it's like almost experiment with drugs
in undergrad that's where scholar 3
comes in
it's a gateway drug to then potentially
more hardcore functional languages
like haskell do you think c and c plus
plus c plus plus still has the role
no i think rust is completely placed a
need for them go and rust
you know those are the the two twins of
doom i mean google create a go
just to get rid of c they hated c that
much and then uh rust is just a
phenomenal language
can be a great motivator
you